and welcome to what is a continuation of
the bullet chest
championships here we have the all-star
event my name is grand mastermont
hamilton and
very excited to be joined by a familiar
face from this week's competition grand
master daniel naradiski what's up buddy
hey i'm on good to be here i'm super
excited about this unfortunately the
bullet championship didn't quite go my
way but let's forget about that because
we have a lot of matches to play today
and all of them are going to be super
interesting
yeah and and i mean getting into the
format for today want to remind people
exactly
what they're going to be looking at of
course uh we do have some of your
favorite streaming personalities there's
going to be an eight player bracket
uh matches are going to be a 15 minute
countdown clock much the same as the
bullet chest championship countdown
clock that you guys are familiar with
one minute chest across the board we're
ready for those dirty flags and of
course if the match
is tied and i hope we do get some of
those then we will go
into sudden death and uh the high seat
gets white first
for that game so moving on to the prize
fund i guess uh dania i mean how about
the prize fund you get money just by
showing up
you do and hey if you win first place
that's a cool 3 000 bucks um
i know some things that you can get
three thousand bucks uh maybe a lifetime
collection of uh
gaming mice i have a couple of ideas but
those are some pretty handsome prizes so
this is gonna be pretty high stakes yeah
i like the suggestion for maybe a
lifetime supply of gaming mice
especially for bullet we all know just
how many of those yeah exactly
we all know how many of those we can go
through well we've we've talked about
the prizes the format but don't forget
about the players this these are the
match-ups that uh we're going to be
seeing today and you know scrolling top
to bottom there it's nice to see a few
canadian flags in the mix but uh dania
any any matches stand out to you here
well really all of them are really
interesting i'm super excited to see
maurice
play i'm a big fan of this style that's
going to be a fascinating match
uh nemo and anna is going to be our
first metric that's a marquee matchup
really all of them
i think have the potential to be to be
close and to be super interesting
yeah we have we see the bracket on
screen there you mentioned maurice
uh tanya has some some names even uh
sean sent he's been streaming a lot road
to gm so
obviously the point of this tournament
is featuring a lot of those
personalities that
uh you know might not be good enough to
make it in to the main tournament
with uh players the likes of yourself
dania but certainly an exciting format
featuring some people that
you know everyone watches on stream
every day
no absolutely this is going to be super
promising the way i played yesterday i
think
some of these players would have
advanced that they played me
[Laughter]
well this is going to be an exciting
show but of course we want to make sure
to give a big shout out to our
presenting pump
sponsor for the bullet chest
championships that's susquehanna
international group s i g susquehanna
international group is a global
quantitative trading firm that uses
strategic games like chess
to improve their decision-making skills
and it's one of the largest
proprietary trading firms in the world
so
a big shout out to sig who has made this
whole week possible danny
absolutely and i'm pretty sure they've
got some pretty serious chess players in
that company
uh sounds like it goes hand in hand so
super exciting stuff i'm on
yeah no it definitely goes uh hand in
hand and uh basically you guys can
expect
uh interviews with the players and
that's exactly what we're going to be
getting set up for right now
so we want to make sure we get everyone
on screen on screen get the trash talk
out
and get ready for uh what could be some
dirty flag and bullet chest today so
dania we are going to take a very short
break while we get set up with the
players
and we'll be back with the action right
after this
[Music]
and dania and myself are back but we're
joined by
two lovely ladies here that is nemo and
anna kramling
start with you nemo welcome to the show
and i mean bullet chess
all-stars you're about to get into a
15-minute bullet match with
anna kremling thoughts this is gonna be
really exciting
it's gonna be hype oh yeah oh yeah
oh yeah for sure anna you feel the same
way
yeah i mean i'm the lowest rated player
in this tournament and i'm playing the
first round against the highest rated
but i mean
i'm super excited wait i'm the highest
rated
oh wait you're maybe not the highest
rate i thought you were
i have no idea what everybody else's
rating is yeah you're not supposed to be
complimenting each other anna stop that
did you not get the memo i mean come on
anna okay so one thing you did have
correct is you're definitely the
underdog
in this match but uh you and i we also
had you know a bullet bullet match
recently maybe uh
getting you some confidence there so how
you feeling about your chances against
nemo today
i have been grinding bullet this whole
week
i mean i've been setting up matches i
played against amman and you know i won
some games there
and i i've been grinding bullet all week
i feel ready for this
to that yeah i played 250 games on
bullet on march 31st
and i have refused to play like chess
for the rest of this week because i'm
so burnt out so i've been like doing
everything
like just just you know coaching i've
been playing violin i've been playing
flute i'm just like trying to get myself
to not be like like you know when you
play too much chess and then you hit
like a wall and then you just never done
that
my
250 games of bullet per match of course
it wouldn't relate but
yeah um so i've been chilling a little
bit and i'm definitely just you know
hyped to get back into bullet i took a
week break on purpose so this is going
to be the best
reintroduction i think for me to get
back into the bullet grind
nice nice anna what do you make of that
you've been training bullet all week
working hard at chess
and your opponent has been playing
violin
violin is a bit playing the violence a
bit of exaggeration i make
really really bad cat noises on the
violin
i have to say you inspired me your
musical journey has inspired me the
other day
i i did a little concert with the guitar
in my screen man
oh nice then thanks to to seeing your
you know
violin talent i thought that i had to
give the guitar a shot so
thank you i like hearing that yeah um
my violin is absolutely terrible my
stream would much prefer it if i just
never played the violin and only played
bullet but
you know they can't have everything they
want
too modest and two wholesome of mine
right exactly two
modest and two wholesome we'll we'll uh
let these girls go
dania and and get into their match um
indeed good luck
exactly thanks to these two musicians
for joining us in the call
well uh girls we'll let you get into
your match best of luck to both of you
all right thank you all right
and uh wow that was a an interesting
interview danny it seemed like we didn't
we didn't have to do much just let them
talk to each other
no no they had a lot to say and um
well they're very nice but i think
they're reserving the um
the real competitiveness and the
bloodthirsty mentality for the chess
board which is how it should be
cause we got 15 minutes of bullet
exactly exactly you guys can see the
bracket there on screen and uh obviously
top left corner is that first match up
nemo definitely the favorite here but
dania if you if you're coming into this
match as
anna kremling do you think there's maybe
some mentality like hey i've got nothing
to lose and that might help her
oh for sure and i mean i think anna
should really do her best to set a good
tone when maybe the first game
because it's a higher rated if you fall
into a hole early and i can
say this from experience yesterday
there's nothing quite like
uh digging a hole for yourself in a
short bullet match so if anna can play a
nice first game
put the pressure on yumu immediately i
think uh that might be the pathway for
her to try to score an upset but nemo is
a bullish stalwart of course
that's going to be top yeah no that's a
great point obviously nemo coming in
the rating favorite um definitely uh the
big favorite in this match but
at the end of the day you make a good
point sometimes uh the
the fact that this is really a you know
fun streamers match
uh don't forget they're playing for cash
as well so we'll see if
maybe nemo takes her foot off the pedal
there and
and let's anna creep into this too much
because i i also did some
recent odds matches against anna and i'm
telling you daniel she's no slouch
no i've definitely i've seen some
vanna's games um
and you know i think she's focused and
she's he's capable of finding some
really strong tactics and
bullet is the sort of thing that really
can be decided by
one particular moment one move um and
sometimes one mile slip
one time scramble so we'll see which one
of those it'll be
yeah absolutely and what what do you
think about this format of 15 minutes
does that
uh generally benefit like the the higher
rated player or the lower rated player
i'd say the lower rate of player i'm on
because it's you know
they say in basketball i think this
common wisdom where the underdog team
wants
they want to hang around until the
fourth quarter and then you never know
what happens in the last two minutes
uh it's the same in a lot of sports and
it's the same thing here
you know you win two games with some
sort of a tactic and all of a sudden you
know there's two minutes left so there's
a lot of uncertainty
i think this benefits benefits the
low-rated player um so this is going to
be really really interesting to see
yeah no that's a that's a great point
and this should be a pretty uh fun match
it's the first one of the day but
uh don't worry we have so many more
coming as you can see
the girls on screen and wow they just
look so energetic
dania so full of energy just bobbing and
and vibing
and hopping yeah yeah there's no sign of
nervousness here
i i said it before when uh i did a
stream with anna but
every time i see her stream i feel like
she's streaming on top of a medicine
ball and just bouncing up and down
that's that's a pretty interesting
observation yeah i can totally see that
but maybe nemo's listening to
a record of her own violin play but as
she does that we have the first game
yep 2400
rating here is nemo uh that is some uh
that's
that's a big time rating here for this
uh it is this match
we have a sicilian with nemo taking a
little bit more time
two bishops now this is a complicated
position i i
kind of like what anna's doing so far
yep agreed
and may as well be a little greedy there
taking on b2 why not
and nemo going for the attack
transferring your queen to g3 but anna
side stepping it
now white starts to gain the initiative
i think yep
oh and now that's a piece oh
this is gonna hurt and bishop g7 would
have been even more clinical but now
it's completely winning
yeah yeah the only uh the only chance
here would be
you know the the famous back ranked
checkmate but i don't think nemo's gonna
let that happen
yeah maybe something dirty and you know
these considerations factor and when do
you resign do you want to conserve time
but it's too early to think about that
yet
uh i think come on there's plenty of
time uh nothing tragic is happening nemo
very convincing here in
in the way she's executing uh this and
converting this advantage
yep i i think it's pretty likely she
wins a rook here
g8 this queen takes f6 and yeah like you
said this is
fairly clinical but usually in the first
couple games daniel do you think it's
maybe a strategy even if you're dead
lost like this
you sort of want to play it out to get
get a feel warm up your moves also see
how quick your opponent is and how their
conversion skills are
yeah for sure and you know this cliche
you never know what will happen in
bullet it's actually true
um and my bullet experience
it's not about what has happened it's
it's more about what hasn't happened and
really the answer to that is nothing so
of course uh
anna resigning there she loses the
second rook and now
white team she's up again to a pretty
pretty good start this is a
unknown line but i kind of like why it's
positioning her particularly for bullet
she's got the center right a4 though
[Music]
and she said ah you know what i wasn't
really feeling that move at all
yeah but now cd and bishop oh it's still
there
oh that would have been very nasty and i
would would have had to take with a
knight
yeah due to the pin well here you go
daniel executing your brilliant tactic a
move too late
a day late and uh i never remember is it
a dollar late and
it's a day late and a dollar shorter
exactly daily dollars for it or should i
say canadian knowledge
not worth that much no we're we're
improving dania though we're coming back
we're coming after the american dollar
soon
all right so we have a complicated
position here are two savings better
i still like in a central control but
that's a nice mode yeah 97 going to d5
is a really good rerouting i
love that move though just a sneaky one
almost oh yeah i'm not doing anything
over here you didn't see anything
right i'm not threatening checkmate's on
h7 so positionally that knight on d5 is
a beast
but look at the holes near black's king
that can be more weighty enough in the
time scramble all these mate threats so
i like what end is doing with that pawn
and f6 potential lobster pincer
meanwhile drops her rook back love it
this is uh shaping up nicely maybe
it's time to send that h-pawn up the
board but ooh gotta keep that f6 pawn so
important
p7 their a7 can be captured letting the
slip is in a bishop c5
now a pin love that move oh oh oh and
bishop g7
wow that's cool yeah and it's so
unfortunate because
whether you saw that or not it was the
only move to play as black
wow and that is an annoying situation to
face where
yeah there's literally no other way to
prevent checkmate and the move happens
to be a crusher
yeah and he was going to take the second
one
she is and uh i was about to say that i
thought in that game we were gonna see
our first time scramble um and i was
interested to see
how the girls matched up in speed
because i definitely know how good nemo
is but
anna at 2100 is is actually very
dangerous on the clock at the end of the
game as well
yeah and i can see that in the opening
she's playing fast and confidently
bishop e3 i'm
not sure about that move i think anna's
she's getting off to great starts
in the opening i think there's just that
pivotal middle game moment where maybe
she can take a little bit more time d5
a great position for black yeah and you
got to be careful how you take this
bishop back
well there you go that's exactly why and
queen c6 oh there was bishop d7
and anna's up a piece this is a big
chance
yep this has to be uh capitalized on i
think if you're anna this is the exact
moment where you make your stand in this
match
ten minutes approaching uh left here and
up a piece as you mentioned
and that sleep rumbling down the board
thundering down the runway now fork but
be careful
careful h7 good g6 but you're
orchestrating some chances for page four
this is not over yet
yep bishop f5 you're going to sacrifice
in a heartbeat
think twice yeah particularly not you
know doctor 10 credit is watching
but don't take on h7 that would be
premature maybe if the queen can get
somewhere to h6
maybe c4 here dislodging the knight
could be considered this is not over yet
e3 now looks dangerous yeah
i'm not doing anything if rook takes f5
there it is
oh no no oh and that doesn't help
yeah geez anna that was your chance and
she knows that she's scratching her head
there as you can see the look in on her
stream twitch.tv slash anna kremling
wow and really one can't stress it
enough the openings have been
super successful uh but at some point i
mean nemo's just so tricky
resilient in every position i've
experienced that
myself and uh that's really paying off
here as
anna's in trouble down three points with
nightmares she's got to win this one
basically
yep exactly this is um kind of
kind of the turnaround moment um i
thought up a piece last game was her
best chance but she's going to have to
make something out of this game if she
wants a chance of this match
that's a pretty interesting medicine
ball is that one of those medicine
balls in the shape of a chair
yeah you know it's the it's the the new
ones
yeah actually my brother got one of
those and i sat on it for about two
minutes and i was like i'm going back to
my
comfortable slouch encouraging armchair
yeah
exactly that's that's what we need these
days and bishop takes e6 i'm not so sure
about that move but she wants the d6
square
yes and she's going to get it but a2
hangs it's unclear
rook a1 is in anna's pocket but now a7
is defended
right and this knight f5 is
uh yeah decent threat there tale of two
outposts
still not at five but is it that good to
win the h6 fun
look at that knight the gymnastics i
like that move rook d3
she's going for checkmate yeah no that's
uh that's the way you want to do it and
doesn't she
well she at least has a draw here
and maybe bring that jeep on up to g oh
oh
and that's checkmate she is on the board
unbelievable that's incredible that was
just an exquisite endgame effort
the knight going hither and then they're
delivering the checkmate and
anna's still in it oh yeah and you
mentioned that was a turnaround game
uh danya now that there's seven and a
half minutes is
you know is the next one just as
important as the last
yes um seven minutes one just gets the
sense
anna's on a bit of a role she's feeling
more confident she's got a pretty solid
position again
i think she's gotta try to strike here
yeah and i i would
look to push that pawn to c4 uh fairly
quickly she's gonna try to take maybe
the two bishops but nemo's not giving it
up
and nemo bringing her knight to five now
i like white's control over those light
squares in the center and the two
bishops nemo advancing upon bishop g5
is possible there comes c4 yep i like
knight c5 though big fan of that move
e4 here is interesting time advantage
for hannah
right time advantage fana is very
relevant that's one thing that i think
as the lower rated player danny is a
good strategy always just try to play
fast
you might not be able to produce as many
good moves as your counterpart but
playing quickly
uh helps a lot indeed imposing practical
and
tactical problems which is exactly what
anna's doing although nemo has
stabilized and they're saying that pawn
on d3
could be a curse rather than a blessing
if it gets weak and that rook on e4
blockading pawn on e5 can fall he's
starting to get a little bit out of
control varana
yep and i might have considered rook c7
there keeping two rooks on the board
instead of trading
because now i'm just worried that nemo's
position is too easy to play but
here comes the black king e4 yep
and establishing a defensive line on the
fourth rank is anna and i like the speed
here
this might be a time scribble one yeah
we've been waiting uh for a while for
for a time scramble between these two
girls
i love time scrambles i'm not even
keeping it a secret
i'm getting out with it oh right
there all the pawns are getting cleaned
up though yeah
the vacuum cleaner is on
it's yeah and now adam's down on the
clock and right i'm just going to wrap
this one up it seems
mm-hmm
but it's just not enough time yeah and
it's going to be challenging
right so i think probably that the math
might check out here
uh dania for a for a comeback but
it's going to have to be you know
picture perfect yeah it's gonna have to
be some nobel prize winning math and
nemo can definitely milk the clock and
if things go wrong here she can
definitely take
almost all or all over time to bleed
more of the clock but
her position seems very very solid out
of the gate here
yeah definitely a good position on the
board uh pawn takes e4
and at night a little concerned about
but it ends up finding a good
good home on c4 yes
and um no this is actually that bishop
on b7 is not very good the square on d6
anna has really skillfully used her
knights but as i say that i had to do a
little bit passive i would have played
rook d1
right and i feel like the queen is sort
of taking the square
the knight wants and meanwhile nemo is
executing a pretty nice attack over here
and rook takes g3 would be at least a
perpetual nemo going for more
queen to d6 or h4 wouldn't move oh but
that knight is doing drop
uh oh uh oh that is uh
a full piece and that queen escapes it's
not getting trapped down there
yep she's got b4 or a5
i like this speed though i really do
like if you're gonna be down a piece
look she's up like 10 seconds every
single game
yep no that's that's great and making
practical decisions just
you know if she cleans up the tactics a
little bit uh she's
she's playing very well but now that
fish is totally dominating this with f5
the
big threat here right so rook trade and
rook d4
try to pick up that b-pawn still looks
reasonable but blender's though
there it is the reaction
yep and now the math i think no longer
checks out
no i yeah i think whatever
boldly and i may venture a bold claim
yeah
and that's not yeah checkmate on the
back rank so
i believe we are trending towards the uh
the diplomatic word trending towards a
victory for nemo here
we're moving toward sort of
all right well we got a semester yeah
and we will have
definitely a couple more bullet games
regardless of the final result let's see
if anna can
get another point on the board she
already has one win under her belt
yep she's broken the ice and she's
demonstrated
great opening knowledge and great speed
in the opening sebastian cobb is a good
choice for bullet it's very dynamic
of course white has that d5 square but
black has chances on on both sides of
the board here and in the center
she plays b5 and she does and this is
usually a good sign for
for black to get this move d5 in i i
have to give a lot of credit to
anna in this match i feel like she's
been out tactic and she's
she's hung some pieces here and there
but really impressed with the speed and
as you mentioned the openings that she's
been getting i just uh paid attention to
that word out tactic that'll be in the
next edition of the
oxford hamilton dictionary that's uh
that's in the current edition if there
is one right
yeah it was it made it made its way and
now uh nemo is the one handling
her night very definitely yeah is going
to be the crusher knight c8 here is even
possible
wow look at that and the knight even
covers d6 and a7
there's no way to stop fun other than
getting up the bishop
right yeah yeah and
a tough decision there bishop v6 but i
think
uh i think anna is going to find herself
on the worst end of this one
and even a5 here would be a flourish
yeah
this would be winning even without the
knight
nemo is clinical just going about it in
the
most savage way super russian skull
chest is going to put a put a knight on
f5 upon an h5 and
vin it like mark doretsky prescribed the
1968 book
i i'm i'm sure she definitely read that
scene totally
i don't think yeah he wrote a book until
the 80s but
i just gotta pretend that i know what
i'm talking about so they have time for
let's see six one is our score probably
the last game
yeah and we'll we'll see whether uh uh
and it can go out swinging because
you know what danny if you're gonna lose
a match there's nothing that feels
better than winning the last game
speaking from experience here myself as
well 100
and the same goes for a tournament if
you have a disaster of a tournament or a
bad tournament
just winning that last game and if you
still lose rating
it's just such a relief because you at
least have you can help hold your head
up line
which she will do anyway of course she's
played well but a nice position here for
when i get a time advantage
i was wondering if we were going to see
e4 we might see it next f4
probably e4 to follow yeah we know three
65's stopping you for and re-preparing
it
okay yeah this looks this looks
pretty reasonable for anna once again a
good opening and
up nearly that 10 second mark once once
more
yeah i kind of like what nemo's doing
here now be careful and if 96 queen b1
is made
but very careful h3 as nemo gets her
knight to e6
yep and captures this pawn
by end of this looks good e6 here e6
wrong order yeah because look at that
long range queen on a2
yeah e6 would have i think been
impression
how about bishop h4 bishop h4 queen
knight takes f7 here
oh yeah oh wow that actually was a cool
mode
okay h4 still i i i like what ann is
doing here
uh i think that when you're in this all
in mode even if you you know
oh your whole queen side is gone but you
just keep sending the attack why not
knight g four uh-huh and again look at
those night maneuvers
all over the bishop f4 yeah nemo's gonna
get her knight to f5 or g8
this might be another win look at the
time taking down yep eight seconds this
is so hard to defend even though these
three puns down and more troubles they
have overnight
when's the knight uh oh and
oh three times
wow that's that's a scintillating finale
actually in
all forest because if the king had gone
to h8 there would have been a night
discovery with checkmate
brilliant that that is that is beautiful
imagine one for the fans
exactly and night discover checkmate so
i mean we got a couple winners in this
match i feel like because
anna with the the victory at the end got
to be feeling good about herself
and nemo of course in all seriousness
moving on in the competition after a
dominating performance
solid not a lot of blunders you know
fast enough
solid fundamentals and uh nemo is is a
stalwart
but definitely not holding her head up
high without a doubt particularly in
that last game i agree
exactly exactly so i mean that was only
the first match for everybody uh so keep
in mind guys
we are going to take a a short break
right now
but we're going to come back with you
know the the next match and the players
of course
on cams so we'll be right back with this
bullet chest championship
all-star presented by sig i got into
playing poker in college
and really liked it but never considered
i could make a career out of it
until jeffy ass came and gave a talk at
harvard jeff explained
that yes you can actually use gaming
skills for your career and for something
to do on a day-to-day basis
which was exciting at the time i thought
it was really cool we can pretty much
guarantee you that we'll give you the
best education you will be taught all
that we know
in a very professional manner by expert
teachers and
you're going to be mentored and i like
to think that there's no other place
where you can get as much mentorship as
you can
at susquehanna i think that the main
thing that everybody has in common
is a sense of competitiveness and
interest in in gaming and
strategy in general i would say you're
you're playing a game as a career
it's very satisfying to me that we've
been able to employ so many people
give them not just an opportunity to
make a lot of money but to be with the
smartest people in the world and to have
a lot of fun and make a lot of friends
and create a culture of reason
[Music]
and dania and myself have returned but
we brought some guests with us that is
international master tanya saktav and
grandmaster maurice
ashley welcome to both of you maurice
i'm just gonna go
right to you uh thanks for being on the
show and we're about to get into some
bullet today maurice i know that you've
just started streaming
very regularly recently have you been
practicing bullet at all
i do play some bullet i gotta admit
because i you know when i first started
i realized how much i sucked at it it's
like i'm really bad
compared to you know guys like donya for
example who are
absolute geniuses at it so at any rate i
i have do i do it for fun you know it's
popcorn for me
it's a good way to just pass the time
and did you have to make me blush
but tanya i got the same i got the same
question uh
for you have you been keeping up the
bullet um do you focus mostly on blitz
how have you prepared for the tournament
neither actually but ever since i found
out that i'm playing momo then i've been
taking it a bit seriously
maurice and i've had some adventures in
saint louis and
uh so i hope our friendship survives
this one
what friendship what are you talking
about
yeah now that the match is technically
the interview is part of the match so
now it's underway maurice is throwing
everything out of the window until after
the match you know what i have to say he
did mention that he's been preparing
very hard for this one right before we
went live
so don't believe anything he says i'm
from the wesley school of preparation
and that is
take a good nap that's that's that's my
preparation
it's actually 1am for me
so don't even try excuses maurice
already
yeah she's starting the excuses i'm
saying i prepared my mapping
i'm serious when i say that i got my
rest in so i'm just saying
i'm gonna do this half asleep well
whatever you got to say tanya you could
tell that we both really hate each other
so we're gonna go at it see what happens
yeah it's that time before lunch and
dinner on the east coast so
i uh you know but there will be no
napping um
during your match i can i can sense the
tactics already beginning before the
first move is played
exactly exactly well i mean it sounds
like we have two competitors dania that
are
really ready to get in the ring so i'm
not gonna delay this any longer than it
needs to be tanya
maurice uh good luck to both of you good
luck and enjoy the match
thank you so much much appreciated play
well tanya youtube
all right that's i mean just can't get
them to
you know no no bad bone in their body
hey daniel no uh
just just no they're they're too sweet
uh but
there will be some bad bones
[Laughter]
get her out of there go play your match
how dare you invade the country
well you could see the uh the bracket
there on screen for a second but
um the the the match obviously top right
of your screen is maurice ashley
tanya saktev um grand master versus
international master
but uh would you say daniel that uh
probably maurice you know a little bit
from the older generation right
less practice than bullet probably
although i
you know i don't know i feel like
maurice i think i have just been playing
just grinding hundreds of bullet games
on some secret account
yeah and he's obviously very very
tactical so that could serve them well
it's really to me it's it's i i honestly
have no idea how this match is gonna go
which is why i'm
i'm so excited i think everybody is
maurice definitely from the old school
i mean i wonder if because they're both
commentators of mine if they hear their
own voices
commentating their own games while
they're playing yeah
that's an interesting point that um you
know tanya probably does more
commentary bringing more visas maybe as
well more commentary work than matches
so
the fact that they they're sitting there
and we're commentating they're actually
playing might might throw them off of it
right no that's that's just a state of
affairs that they might not be used to
but they seem to be all smiles but
i can guarantee you that the moment that
that white clock begins
uh the smiles well slowly but surely are
going to dissipate and be replaced with
mouse exactly exactly and and maurice
has been
streaming very regularly recently which
uh you know i'm a big fan of
of maurice and happy to see him on the
platform uh streaming more and
he's been going over some games so i
think that at least he will be
a bit more familiar with you know moving
the mouse online gameplay
flagging stuff like that so that's
probably going to help him
yeah for sure and i've seen maurice play
uh blitz
a couple of times in person in st louis
i've seen him play with yasser and
you know he's he still has that speed he
still has that
spring in his step which i think is
going to translate but
i mean i i hope to see some time
scrambles and i wonder if that's that's
the big x factor who is going to
emerge victorious in those sub 30 second
scenarios
and they are off they are indeed
quite an even match up just if you look
at the ratings alone
and tanya playing a con set up a maurice
played this
sort of delayed smith morrow c3 he's got
a really nice position as the rook will
come to c1
yeah love that rook c1 bishop f4 hitting
that d-pawn
and i'm wondering after e5 whether he's
gonna regret closing the position up
yeah it appears to be the case although
he plays it you know very old school
uh grabbing space on the queen side but
tanya now has this plan of h6 f5
tanzanian 7 now knight g5 mike tom
bishop g5 instead by maurice yeah i
agree i i feel that the the knight was
uh well placed on g5 to head into e6 but
nevertheless
giving up the dark square bishop here is
maurice and he's going for squares on
the queen side
yep he's getting his knight to b6 that's
super nasty he's got the blockade on e4
he still has a very nice position he's
up a little bit on the clock
this is looking good for white it is
tanya needs a bit more speed in a
position like this
knight v6 and oh look at that queen and
rook comes into c7 and now you can hear
maurice's voice just narrating the
events as the pieces get in
yeah this is the type of position where
you can definitely be sure that the
engine feels that white has a good
position yes
i'm pretty sure why it does um h3
workouts do on everything seems to be
good here
or he's keeping the speed
yeah knight d7 not a move i'm a big fan
of just because
you know i'd be too proud of me trapping
the queen in there
oh oh that's a queen oh
oh my goodness nobody has played bullet
in a while i feel like in this
right they got to get those engines
dusted off
it appears that murray's gonna keep the
speed going he's gonna win but he's
gonna move fast trying to prove
him g5 running the rook oh check
how did that sort of work out with and
it's not fast enough as we see tanya
able to laugh that one off but i think
it's better dania that maybe they don't
know
how many moves the queen was hanging for
right no because then that's all
they would be thinking about uh going
forward that's how these things work so
let's make sure we're not telling them
until the end well maybe
ever before let's let them find out
exactly one day down the line
you know two years later in st louis
daniel's gonna whisper in maurice's year
about the queen hanging right exactly
over uh you know over cocktails and
yep in some rustic mansion
closing ceremony exactly a closing
ceremony somewhere it honestly is better
though for bullet sometimes
that you don't know those mistakes
because they truly will haunt you and
you'll be thinking about them here when
you shouldn't
should be focusing on this position
where guys we're attacking on both sides
of the board here
indeed as marie strikes first taking
upon me tanya doing a very good job
ignoring that
pushing down the h now g4 bishop h6 this
is a super textbook super classic attack
very hard to parry amon in a bullet game
that h file now wide open
agreed uh wholeheartedly this this
attack very
old school very calculated and i just
love it for tania i think it's probably
going to work out
and maurice trying to weaken white's
king with tonya tucking it away in the
corner
fearless here is maurice using his queen
to probe
i thought rook d3 might have been more
active now yeah now e5 is interesting
but at least maurice manages to
take the queens off the board right i'd
like to move e5 there instead of g5
um rook f1 king b2 or rook c1
take the c5 yeah this is looking good
for tanya she's up on time
objectively it might be right around
equal but an
ambassador would have been h4 i'm not a
fan of that one that just drops the pawn
right and tanja is going to take that up
f4 would be good here as she reroutes
the rook back to c1 trade of knights
this is looking very grim for maurice
right and i would have taken with the f
pawn on e6 and played bishop c6 instead
the rook is actually just walking
circles around the bishop here
right but the clock is going to play
the decisive role that's correct yeah
even
even though white is dropping
87 nice little bullet trick there dania
yeah very very uh classy getting the
rook to f6 and now pre-moving the king
moves
and it's 1-1 it is i have a feeling this
is going to be an extremely close match
yep i just one gets that sense with 10
minutes left
in the match scores one one race to the
white pieces
and here we go so this uh this position
i would say
is already one that um both players are
probably familiar with in a classical
sense this doesn't feel like
like a bullet position this is just this
is just you know mainline like english
catalan stuff
yeah this is something you'd see in the
ironian
running mvl you know wake up see 2016
kind of stuff
and tiny playing it solid bishop d6 kind
of cutting into the pin
maybe maurice is slightly better he's
got more space e4
is a possibility here it's easier to
play than goes before i like what he's
doing here
yep he's got an age
queen takes preventing the move c5 at
least temporarily
doubling the rooks
and tanya preparing c5 right and queen
e5 so
we could actually get some sort of end
game where white's bishop ends up better
than black's bishop i can sort of
uh see the the tea leaves
you can see the chiles is that a
canadian expression
you know it's it's uh from harry potter
obviously oh
i just thought of like a tea leaf salad
you know i you know getting a burmese
restaurant anyways
uh we'll table that for a later date
yeah we'll save that discussion for
but maurice is not able to see five pawn
for later today as he snags that one
this is looking
very grim for tanya unless you can find
a way to get maurice's king trapped in
some sort of a perpetual this clock is
also concerning neumann
yeah and in fact if you if you just sort
of plant the black queen behind the
pawns or on d4
as tanya is doing with the time taking
down this is not the easiest conversion
queen b7 you got a frame of that
and he's taking about two seconds three
seconds to move that's way too long
because tanya will have checks in her
pocket
right good move there queen d5 there we
go
and we're starting to get the the pre
moves in
doesn't go for a perpetual there jk7
back to e387
nice pre-move oh look at this
he's gotta go gotta go that's a pre-move
queen
gotta be close you know what daniel i
think he didn't have autoqueen on there
i thought it took too long mcqueen
gotta take both pawns now take the pawn
there you go oh
and he does and he might still win this
oh my god i knew you didn't have auto
queen on there was no
chance i actually haven't had it on
sin until recently believe it or not
really
is that yeah you actually believe like
statistically
you you need to underpromote more uh
believe it or not it's it's more of the
psychology of being able to do that
uh overrides the fear of the stalemate
scenarios which is totally irrational
but i agree with you in that case i
think
maurice maybe not quite as experienced
in those time scrambles internet time
scrambles
auto queen would be a good idea yeah and
i just can't get over
promoting to a night and then not having
another move ready just
that that he expected that move to just
knock her out
right wow
so we have a sort of an iqp position
where he's doing a good job blockading
d5
yeah and yeah hard to say i mean i don't
think whites
might white white's pretty solid here
but black is definitely
in the driver's seat oh
rook c8 here there's friendship v8 i
guess
and oh blood is a rook a full rook
oh
another one of those queens indians so
we've got a lot of those catalan queens
indian kind of openings here
this could get really good really fast
if if you go to e5 here
bishop to d3 might have been a slightly
more active square but yeah d-pod this
is still very very good for white
yep yeah bishop on b7 guys i mean it's
just
looking at this granite on d5 supported
by c4
it's biting on granite and yeah marie's
developing naturally so in
these positions are the worst in bullet
amount because of how easy they are to
play rookie one
all these natural moves you can play
very quickly double the rooks
and that's what he does exactly it's the
speed that you can i mean
you're seeing it here uh actually
maurice is supposed to be the one who's
up on time all these quick moves but
he tends to take these like two three
seconds per move
um all the time which is totally
understandable
if you know if you haven't had that much
experience
um you know and and sometimes the free
moves do backfire but
this also could backfire tanya is
keeping you know sort of a four second
advantage here and
she hasn't dropped anything yet her
position remains solid
yeah the interesting thing about
positions like this that i find in
bullet
as black your position is so bad that
there's so many things to improve upon
and as white you feel compelled to to
make something happen because your
opponent's position is not that
active and that's kind of what we see
here although 95 i'm not a fan of look
at that d5 pawn
maurice has got to go g4 looks good
there f5 by tanya maybe
yeah f5 by time it does look like it
scoops up that pawn
there we go yay this time disparity 10
seconds
down is maurice oh but that's a big pawn
to lose huh
tanya's got some checks which he's got
to be careful now not to get checkmated
there queen e6 is a huge threat
take back and go to e3 oh he's got to
move though this is unacceptably slow
gotta move gotta go no
so we was definitely startled by that i
think we saw a total of one move in
seven seconds there for maurice
yeah probably not going to cut it in
bullet no
no and maurice is always good natured
um that's why we love him but he was
definitely startled by that
yeah you know they sort of lean back in
your chair
you're in the headlights it's like oh
right the time is actually a part of
this game
in a big way right okay
so the score two and a half two and a
half you called it about four minutes to
play
this is going to come down to the wire
yeah it really is
we're gonna get um probably two to three
more games out of this one
and uh that means that we're you know if
we go one and one in the next two we
might have a very important
uh you know deciding final game
right and yet again we have one of these
wishy-washy kind of structures in his
knight of six coming queen c4
yeah hard to recommend a move here
f5 or something and again that time look
at that time
f5 seems to be i agree we only tried uh
rook d4 and now this reinforces the
threat rook 64 with c7 is crushing yeah
yeah we see his idea though he did want
that fork however rook c7 nice little
internet so they're attacking the queen
ah don't sleep on maurice as he went
back to exchange rook c8 forces the
trade that is good for black
what can come to c2 at the end uh oh
this is flipping around completely
rook c2 pretty much pre-moved there and
he's starting to show some oh
d4 coming uh oh d3 d3
this is over wow well
it's close the the only thing i will say
that's huge i think tanya should maybe
play that out
yeah based on his one move in seven
seconds
uh reputation i think that that was that
was a flag and a couple moves there for
tanya
yeah but the thing is you know one
adapts very very quickly
um and bullet you have that internal
metronome
and yet again we have i think both sides
are playing kind of the same
type of opening and i don't even know
what exactly this is
oh knight c3 there's knight g5 there's a
common trap here
and i think maurice knows it yep he was
planning for that and that's why f5
played but knight d2
this already is is tough gotta play g5
looking at e5 square
or he's gonna come back to f3 if he
wants he does i feel like we're watching
like a a classical chess match in fast
forward
classical chess match and fast forward
yeah that's actually a very good way to
put it because of the openings and the
type of positions that occur
yeah exactly i feel like we're watching
papa blanca against like
i don't know zigbertarash or rihar
takeman
yeah you know these openings yeah and
and of course uh
i think probably tarash would be wearing
a hat that says against the chess on it
right
he was uh he was not the most uh modest
individual i think so maybe he'd be
wearing hell that would say
i am dr zigbertars the greatest chess
philosopher in the history of the game
and i am not a jerk okay
tanya needs to speed up big time here
because
she loses this game the match is over
right i mean she should have honestly
such develop developed your pieces
earlier but
impressive okay i have seven out of
seven knight f7 is screaming at daniel
oh right idea wrong execution now it's
gonna be typical
that's a queen though oh man tanya you
gotta play this on don't resign no
no okay but now she's gonna win quit
well
no worries can sit it out basically he's
gonna have to win uh
insanely quickly he's gonna have to
repeat the name
indian uh have you not heard him on
about the six move nimzo indian
checkmate it was recently played by um
by team rajab and the candidates that
hasn't occurred yet
he basically refuted this opening i i i
haven't seen it but you know
you know who i trust to to know it is
tanya definitely cut you know
commentating those top-level matches
right no for sure and
i don't know what that was but this
one's officially over regardless
how it does that is the most reassuring
feeling in the world you can it's it's
feeling parallel by getting a title norm
before the last round knowing that it
doesn't matter how you do
yep which usually means you lose the
game by the way right
it actually does funny hour that works
yeah rook c8 here and you know maurice
has got a solid position he doesn't mind
even playing like maybe a knight c4 i'm
not sure if that works
yeah no this is good for tying a knight
on e4 practically but murray's preparing
f5
d5 though would win we need e5 by white
still b5 is an idea
maurice repositioning that time you're
giving him what he wants with e3 i like
yep yep that looks like a strong move
yeah ed e4 maybe it's my
idea and are we gonna see the you know
the prophecy come true that you as soon
as the match is won you just lose the
last game
i think we will well i gotta put my
reputation on the line you know
exactly and you mentioned the word
prophecy my ears broke down
don't get too excited here this is
exactly what we practiced for
um all right well it just seems like the
time
yeah and 95 would be stronger tanya's
got to go fast and
erase the pre-move all right so the many
premiums look at this
very impressive by maurice it's like he
he needs to just turn on these jets
earlier right not those jokes he used to
fly to laguardia hear it oh yeah
that is he didn't find it but he's got
to go
oh look at that bullet stop for maurice
overkill
the prophecy does come true wow
and both of them are laughing but
maurice carries this match four and a
half three and a half
right well old school prevails exactly
and i mean what a fitting end to a match
like that
it seems like i felt like i was watching
two players
learning to play bullet and and that
time scramble at the end was like the
final exam
right no that was yeah exactly that's
when all of the material that you
learned
is brought to bear what a match
goes on you can see the scores there
on the screen obviously we had the nemo
match first and then maurice
took that one down four and a half to
three and a half against tanya so
that will be uh the last we see of tanya
in this event but maurice is moving on
dania
yes he is and uh he's going to base some
stalwart opposition um the likes of
nemo and we have two more matches to go
and
uh those players are definitely going to
have something to say about that too
so certainly don't go anywhere get
alexander beautiful
exactly alexandra you guys have to stay
tuned i mean
that was a lot of fun that match but
there's going to be a lot more just like
it so
stay right where you are we're going to
get the next set of players in
for the interview and we'll be right
back with the bullet chess championship
all-stars presented by sig after this
[Music]
and we have returned danny and i brought
a few friends with us we're joined by
bartosz and
alexandra bartosh i mean you gotta tell
us right off the bat
what's with the uh the dress up you
looking pretty fancy over there
i i mean i think this is how we just
regularly dress up to games we like to
dress for success nothing wrong with
some well-dressed chess players
exactly for first time also when i was
playing against alexandra i had an idea
to
take a seat and wear this and
it gave me a win so i try and do it
again and that's
that's why also uh uh i
wear a seat right now
well alexander there were some fighting
words exchanged before the match can you
bring that to our attention there was a
talk of a previous match that apparently
it happened who won that match and
was that part of your pre this match
strategy yeah i mean i really wanted to
bolster
poland's economy so you know we did a
match where i
gifted him a hundred subs and it was
close he won by one game i wanted to
make sure he felt
confident going into the real bullet
chess championship
i think your volume cut out when you
said who won that match can you
sorry i think the volume cut out
continue daniel
technical issues uh as always on the
broadcast we just
we might never find out who won that
match alexandra what about your
background today you you've come in with
a polish flag of your own it looks like
i mean if i'm here to take poland's
number one streamer down i just wanted
to make sure that the
the polls would feel home at home with a
new streamer to support after i beat him
wow well versus are you uh are you
planning to
just take that or are you gonna gonna
try to make some moves to
to rectify that situation okay i guess i
i'd like to show my skills i know that
alexandre is who meant to be the master
so i do my best i've had many
many information which alexandra told
viewers that
uh i'm not able to win this but i guess
it will be interesting
uh so much overall so yeah
no it definitely will be an exciting
match uh we're excited to see
um your match bartosz and alexandra
obviously everyone is familiar with
you on the uh on the streams but uh bar
shows also
streaming uh in polish one of the
biggest polish streamers
right now so bar any anything you want
to say to your polish fans before we get
started
yes if if i can say something i will say
only
one word but as bizarre
i don't know what that means but i
appreciate it i'm sure it's in good
faith
yeah it must have been nice yeah did
that mean challenge
anyways yeah daniel we we're gonna
practice
our polish well we let you guys get to
the match so
without further ado guys thank you for
joining the broadcast
of course best of luck to both of you
luck who emerges victorious
thank you very much and i wish you good
luck uh alexandra
i wish it will be a great so much good
luck to you
well so so courteous at the end of one
yeah
good luck yes just get out of here
exactly let's just let's start the
let's start the blood uh you know the
bloodletting
yeah i gotta gotta start rolling the the
oscar's credits at some point
play the music looks like he's attending
the wedding of some
of some dignitary exactly yeah if he's
either attending the wedding or serving
the drinks and
both of those sound very exciting they
do and
um please i'm trying to tie that into
a coffee that i suppose the neurons
aren't firing fast enough
and uh wow there's just so much going on
even before the game started
it's like swinging from side to side as
a polish flag behind her
what's going on here i know this is wild
that we have the
the awesome suit by bartosz i think i
think the dress-up
suit is amazing more people daniel
should be playing bullet chest
more people should be flagging in a suit
oh absolutely and i've had bad
experiences with that because i
even yesterday i kind of dressed up
nicely but the long sleeves
uh you know make it a little bit they
put up some resistance when you're
making certain moves of the mouse as you
can understand
and that is of course the reason i lost
standard tank was because of the suit
that i decided to wear
so let's hope barters doesn't experience
the same problems
exactly exactly and they i see i feel
like they color coordinated
maybe you know they they took it upon
themselves this was a
you know match up for the the honor of
poland but they're they're color matched
in red here
dania so i like i'm liking the
coordination yeah i like how
bartus is drinking out of some you know
some goblin you know some royal goblet
and i'm just drinking my
root beer from chick-fil-a i feel
inappropriate
yeah exactly we're just we're just in
our regular setups here and i feel like
bartol she's coming
to us live from the grand palace right
and i
there's like a vampire face there um
are you sure he's not coming to us from
transylvania well
at this point i mean we're just trying
to come up with
quips about the players backgrounds as
we're waiting for this match to start
right we are waiting for that start and
it will begin wow whatever what a close
match i'm on wow
that second game man i'm still
they just can't get any separation again
no matter how hard they try
right yeah
alexander yeah now they're like
repositioning themselves
we might have to work on our polish as
well i mentioned it there but
you know i think by the end of this
match we we need to learn one new polish
word you know
yeah i mean i've gotta admit a little
bit of an advantage with that because
you know written polish i can understand
maybe
30 40 um but
spoken uh just individual words here and
there
but it's it's it's very different
promotion but
definitely i'm down i i have a feeling
that
trusting the chat with the polar bear
it's gonna say the same thing
probably not our best questions
i don't know just got this feeling just
got this feeling fully entrust chad to
tell us a word of the language
neither of us knows why would anybody do
anything dirty there
yeah of course uh so
all right well serious progress on the
chessboard here
yep and you mean that literally as the
games are underway and alexandra coming
in with a
2400 bullet rating is uh
definitely i think that might be her
all-time high i think she had a few
challenges going on stream
indeed and we have a very unconventional
opening
you know befitting the attire of these
players something very grand
and quite symmetrical i should say yep
as
alexander might try to get that d2 night
over to b
one and i'm trying to figure out
let's click on there we go there nice
re-wrap b5
i like from black after we save this
queen there
right and alexander does have this
knight on d5 but now bartus
bringing his knight undergo wedging that
pawn in i like this move upward
aggressive by alexandra
yep and i've seen alexandra move the
same piece back and forth
about on four or five different
occasions this match so
really uncertain c5 there would have
been a really really good chance
a little bit too passive here but still
i think alexander and the driver see
that she's got the two bishops
on before this week the parts are solid
very solid
yeah king is coming into the middle here
and sometimes when you have the solid
position it's easier to play you know
you're worse on the chessboard but
you can easily you know make safe moves
and bishop c8
that's a nasty one that pawn fixed by
alexander bishop c1 bishop d2 is the
idea
right barter's coming back to defend it
yeah and that bishop on d8 does a
fantastic job but more pawns on dark
squares here
and is bartolo's gonna bring that knight
to f4 it looks like he wants to
yeah you should take it will there be a
time scramble h4
oh she wins the pawn yeah h4 has a great
loophole
[Music]
oh my land watch for c5 though alexandra
is very dangerous very tricky she is
and he's taking that he's not kicking
each other no what is he doing
oh god
what is he doing
even he doesn't know what he's doing he
can't believe it
wow he can't believe that he won a free
bishop and then repeated the position
drawn game wow
that's okay that's it's not okay
that's what he's trying to tell himself
okay
and another stop he can't pre-move that
alexa
what is that what is
[Music]
come on what is going on this match what
is this match
one of these openings and now we have
another tango
i mean it's a pretty provocative style
which
which is a good thing in bullet and
alexandra mishandling this a little bit
that bishop on c5 can come couple with a
knight on g4 i like the move h3
alexander's gotta calm down here a
little bit but she gives up e4
yeah e4 force hanging for like eight
years so many moves
you know that book by gabrielle garcia
marcus hundred years of solitude
useful i need like a megaphone or
something e4 hello
finally he takes it okay so you don't
want to check the accuracy of this game
afterwards because every move is
probably a blunder there
okay rookie one alexandra marshalling
for forces
yep i just wanted to use that phrase
yeah
i figured because there's a knight on h2
and yeah nice nice marshalling
the marshalling has ended i think e4
there might have been
uh merited consideration perhaps well we
know they're not too fond of that
square if you would prefer to sacrifice
a bishop rather than one
yep oh there we go now it's played and
with that rook coming to e8
this could be very dangerous yep
something tells me this is looking grim
for alexander
yeah although i'm not a big fan a fan of
the queen hang
i'm just not a big fan of it you know
right
alexandra managing to hang two queens in
three games so
i think she's playing better chess than
usual
as we move on to the next game here
getting nervous
just set me off i mean it was
yeah i you do not check the accuracy of
that one that
that's easily like a sub 30 no i mean
i don't think i've ever seen a phone
hanging for that one but wait i'm on
there was the point
on c4 of course but i was only hanging
for a single move
um and now we have another one of these
locked up positions
yep uh bartus preparing before it
appears if you can blast open
yeah i mean g6 maybe would have been
more pointed
now the d file opens the c file might
open with c5
right c5 is something to be seriously
concerned about and play it
really strong move oh bc queen b7 is
made that pawn is untouchable
yeah and the other rook is coming to c1
i don't think you want to trade queens
here yeah that's a better move
and d7 queen b5 sends the king back to
the c c6 and
another one okay so that's three queens
in four games
not too bad i still think i still think
alexander can be happy with the
performance
and bartow she's he's essaying all sorts
of
interesting opening setups right and
then upon other pawn on e5 that's
okay
i don't know what it is about 94 and
this one is looking good for alexander
she's got to win this game in all
seriousness
yeah nine minutes to play i'm on i think
she has to press the gas pedal down this
is her chance
exactly we actually have uh her first
game was her best one and i love the
movie
she's got a threat that is a very classy
positional sequence
and let me not try to jinx well watch
out for queen f3
queen nice queen f4 with an iron fist
okay take on a3 maybe get that queen
involved
what about rook a1 maybe queen d6
hanging the queen
that wasn't too advisable you gotta you
gotta commentate
to your audience right well and you know
what mick deltal said
sacrificing multiple pieces at the same
time you can only take one piece
um at a time so really well alexander
making a little bit harder on herself
that pawn on a5 would have been a nice
asset here her king is a little bit weak
and in all seriousness i really do like
to move h6 by black
before you start pursuing aggressive
options take care of your king make sure
you're not getting background needed
and alexander good free moves here but
she's low on time those light squares
around white's king bishop before
battery maybe yep
okay she's starting to get some
pre-moves in i'm concerned bishop e4
taking your queen okay
queen d1 who won oh no what a what a
good move by alexander though alexander
with f5
fg and now
the king is still a little bit weak but
she's going to go rookie
yeah that's a check 48 covered
covered six seconds for alexander bartos
has the checks he's got the weekend
three mo is made here we go alexandra is
really good at pre-moves but she needs
yeah
she's got the upper hand here and that's
just alexandra
showing her skills in bullets she is
really good at premiums
yes and that's why in in my matches
against her these sort of adoption
matches
you know if i have 15 20 seconds to a
minute
you know she beats me pretty regularly
in 10 second 15 seconds
she's got the mechanics down she knows
that it's had practical problems but
she's got to follow up on this
she's in a french she's comfortable in
these positions
let's hope the queen on d8 has a long
and illustrious life
yeah she's she's improving the last game
honestly was was very clean by alexandra
yep and this one looking good too c5
might come in bishop g5
is down a threat
yep bishop a6 i was gonna say and
she's slowly poking away but uh white's
position
improving getting a lot of space here
okay c6 a little bit passive but still
very solid
but a little bit passive but a little
bit solid
but just a tiny passive but quite a bit
solid now
also solid now it's looking solid right
and now there's no
no no queens left so which is kind of
good
but look at that
okay so what do you make of this end
game here because white has the active
rook would you rather be white or black
here
i will after rookie four i'd rather be
black i think this is probably
this this smells of a three-time rapid
different rook d7
now bartosz i think has the upper hand
with d7 or kept seven
yeah yeah you know the best feeling that
black spawns fall first
yeah whose vacuum cleaner is better here
but i'm not sure
why it's vacuum cleaner it's got a
bissell i don't know too many vacuum
cleaner brands
the evaluation bar seems to know
something that i don't
well that's i often find that to be the
case and after a2
uh oh a2 a2
uh okay so alex agenda there's an
aversion to queens whether they are
manufactured
or kept on the board exactly so she
doesn't want her queen on the board and
she doesn't want any replacements
at all right no no refills
i hate those places with three rifles
now in all seriousness that would not
have been that easy
bart had passers but that was a chance
now
450 a month she's got to win this one
yeah it definitely feels that way so
that's probably the main reason why i
was advocating
so hard for pushing that pawn it still
would be a tough conversion but she also
has to think about the match
situation she does need wins and i feel
like she should have snagged that pawn
on e6 when she had a chance
yeah knight d4 still looks maybe better
for white but now bartus
activating his species and alexander
doesn't have any pawns to show for it
and i don't mind the move g3 um but i
would have maybe gone for king g2 rookie
two to solidify the second rank
rookie seven although rook takes up to
mike black enough counterplay i'm not
sure king f8 and
i think we should be headed towards a
draw here yeah well he definitely now
has a draw
but barton could change maybe you killed
me
this check checkmated one alexandra
misses checkmate in one
and she the look on her face is a girl
who knows it as well
yeah she does she definitely does and
now she's
and she still has a chance 350 to left
and
you know plenty of time she doesn't have
to rush this and it's very important to
realize that
and she's got a nice position here
bartus is not really
you know playing the most vampiric of
openings
but alexander really is sinking her
teeth into that king's side not sure
that's a good thing and
okay so it started with a hypothesis
daniel wasn't sure and i coming in with
proof it is definitely not good right
the scientific method has prevailed once
again
now this is not so easy look at those
funds yep very menacing actually
but a lot of minor pieces
four of them to be exact yeah yeah when
you okay so
now no minor ps4 g4
that's gonna trap the knight on eight on
h3 that's hilarious
now legender might be winning yep i
could see the king just walking into c2
here
king d3 king c2 use that king as an
active piece
rookie three oh this is not that bad
though or which is a nice move
i love that
actually can you maybe rookie three
because the king activity is so
fast that maybe black is winning okay f
two and b five
b four oh c4 is huge
alexander has to try something dirty yep
c3 he's got to try c3
no should shooter played it oh he
wouldn't move yeah he's
he's too good for that dagger i think
oh start is it though they started the
game
there's still oh no it's three games
sorry the score wasn't updated oh
three games i i think even my math
doesn't check out there
well three representing the amount of
queens that were
you know lost in control don't worry we
still have one more game
remember that you're saying there's
still a chance there's still there's
still a number to take up
exactly knight c5 would have been nice
there
what are these close positions yeah i
don't these
these two players have some sort of
force but of course
alexandra doesn't take the pawn because
that would be against the moral code of
closed position
right and you know what's even more
impressive than the queen's
left-hand pawns that have been left
uncaptured
throughout the epochs they they sort of
have antennas like unforced errors i'd
love to see the stat on uncaptured
errors oh
no this one will be captured by
alexander with pleasure
and how about nah another time
now it's time for the pawns oh look at
the defense
this might be better than taking the
rook oh
man gosh this is a oh
i wouldn't even take that bishop no no
no no no you're enjoying this too much
c4 c4 he spoils it
yeah come on alexandra what was that
taking a free piece come on
exactly how dare you root d6 is a very
nice move coming to c6
yep however not locating a checkmate
here
i think we will get another game after
this although it won't change the
outcome of this match
rook c4 mate
now barter's getting some chances 11
seconds for alexandra
take the bishop what oh my god oh no
oh my lands no that's going to be a time
scramble
uh-oh run run alexandra
this is where her strength comes in
she's so good at predicting look at this
exquisite
rook v6 was made but but look how quick
this is exquisite emma this is amazing
yeah it really is it really is that's
where alexandra shines
and i think i'm not entirely sure but i
think the match block might have expired
they've got another game going
maybe it yeah okay that's what i thought
i did
another one man 15 minutes
what a match now now that is a victory
for poland you might be confused with
the polish flag behind alexandra but
fear not bartosz comes away with the
victory
and uh honestly a very interesting style
i wonder if he's gonna be playing closed
positions the whole tournament or if
that was
just for alexandra you know yeah no he
seems to be a
man of many openings and many outfits
um and if his outfit is any uh you know
is taken as evidence then i think he's
he's going to be uh very diverse in his
opening choices but we'll uh we'll see
that's going to be a very interesting
match
but we got one more uh to go before the
next stage i'm on and
let's not sleep on that one and promises
to be an interesting one as well
exactly that's going to be sean against
alessia and
as always just with the last matches we
are going to get those players
in the call cams we want to hear from
their from them and get their thoughts
before we play so we will take a short
break
and be right back with the bullet chest
championship all-star event
presented by sig
[Music]
and mr nareditsky and myself are back
joined by sean and alessia for our
fourth
match of the day and i simply cannot
start this interview
alessia without addressing the the armor
that you've brought to battle today
what's going on there
i'm ready for the battle
i love it have you conducted a
statistical
uh analysis of uh your results when
you're wearing the helmet
versus uh when you're not or is it more
to sort of send a signal to your
opponent
i see that daniel knows about it and yes
oh yeah i remember it
the helmet is bringing me good results
so why not yeah
i gotta use all my skills
understandable and sean uh no doubt you
also tried wearing a helmet and found
better results without one
unfortunately i did not got to say to
ben tim dane
with felicia with that helmet and then
there's
only room for one uh sean to those
unfamiliar you i see you grinding on
stream a lot do you mostly play blitz or
bullet what kind of
bullet experience have you had and uh
how do you feel about
the match in general yeah most i play
combination of blitz and bullet but
definitely
been playing a lot more bullet leading
up to this match feeling like the
bullets in the good spot
today that's exactly where it needs to
be there's going to be
you know 15 minutes of straight bullet
chest alessia
is is bullet chest one of your preferred
formats do you like the quick time
controls
oh yeah i like quick time control i like
to
try to flag my opponent
i will try you're admitting it that's
good
yeah i mean when you're desperate you've
got to try for the flag
you know um i like i like bullets i like
blitz
and yes this this last week was a fully
merchant bullet
after this event i will take one break
or one month
[Laughter]
but yeah we are ready
well that's totally fair although it's
it's hard to sway somebody who's on the
on the road to gm 3000.
so good luck to you sean and good luck
to alessia this
is going to be really interesting nice
yeah
all right we'll let the players get into
the match there
we have sean and alessia both who have
been putting honestly speaking daniel
incredible hours into streaming i see
pretty much every single day on schedule
uh those two are live so if you're if
you're looking for regular channels to
follow
definitely check them out yeah when i
finish my stream at
6 39 a.m i see us streaming and
i see sean streaming as well so yeah
it's um awesome to see that kind of a
grind and both of them seem
ready for battle in alessia's case
literally yeah
actually i think shawn might burst into
into where she's playing
she's got the armor in case wouldn't be
surprised i
i know uh from watching sean's stream
that uh he's gonna need his believers
in chat you know he he's gonna need uh
all the support
that he can get this is a tough one i
know uh from you know playing alessia
firsthand she's got
a ton of energy and loves the flag like
is really
unashamed dania about dirty flagging the
opponent
and uh i totally agree with that
strategy i mean
uh you know preaching the choir and all
but i i think particularly in these
matches i'm on when there's prizes at
stake
one could make the argument for friendly
matches but these everything goes
every strategy goes and i think that's
understood because you
basically have to do anything to win
yeah 100
100 that is exactly what you need to do
and we see the players
on cam there she's still got the helmet
on i wonder dan you think she's gonna
take it off if the the game start going
poorly
uh i think that's possible um but i
guess the
strategy and the notion is that the
games will not start going poorly that's
just not a
i think that's brought onto the table
yeah with the helmet on that that that's
not an option
right it's not on the table just like
the helmet won't be on the table it'll
be on
her head at all times amazing and
representing
italy here and daniel representing danny
wrench with that one
nice right whip well
it's um you know just as simple as a
hamilton and cheese sandwich but
let's watch the game i'm sure you've
never heard that one before bishop takes
f6 there would have been good
uh that d5 pawn is very weak
very weak and i think this is the one
chance i was wondering if the knight was
going to be taken or not
right and maybe there they learned a
little bit from
from the previous match there's some
sort of moral code with with pawns okay
what is going on knight takes d5 there
it looks like a crusher
right 95 and pieces were loose but
actually sean is looking pretty a real
castle
whoa he's still looking good though at
the time advantage
well he's looking like he didn't notice
that rook was hanging so again right
probably
okay queen's you for threatening check
me e6 looks pretty good here
yep careful for that rook i'm seeing
just hanging to some tactic i love the
aggressive play by sean just
full scent okay rookie four looks
interesting queen
queen h5 taking h6 maybe alessia
has to try something that happens f6 or
g2 oh
careful for rookie two and he sees it
really good move by sean there he sees
everything e6 maybe
h5 uh oh wait let's watch that helmet
let's keep a careful eye on it nope it's
not going anywhere
alessia believes i love the profile
picture
of alessia there it's like it's liquor
right exactly if the helmet wasn't
intimidating enough
yeah there couldn't be more contrast you
know sean sort of has his hand on this
sort of thinking buzz yeah like
um you know like that sculpture
who's it who's that spelled rodin
[Music]
dania's bringing more culture to this
stream than than
we need well we have viking culture by
alessia i just got to bring in
you know the sculptures yeah the viking
culture but
yeah representing italy here uh alessia
i know she
i'm not sure if she streams ever uh in
italian at all but um
obviously representing italy for for the
fans out there
absolutely and she's doing a good job in
this position i think she's got that
positional control over the center but
her king that f-file is what really
concerns me
in a bullet game the weaknesses of your
king are amplified because they're very
hard to defend it's time-consuming
that's a good point there and brook
takes c5 light squares for this night i
think
it's not going to work out unfortunately
the vikings would not approve of the
same game no we need we need a
another war cry maybe just the king
let's plunder the rook
as well oh i wasn't even noticed that
was named
maybe if we analyze this position as the
lightning yeah we shall pillar pillage
the rook oh
she did village she's so dirty with it
that was
unreal that's unbelievable but look at
the top she's gotta move
she's gotta move sean pre-moving a three
or three little bit drop
what an unbelievable move unreal
i told you she is unashamed she's got a
move
oh and it doesn't quite buy a hair
and that's what you gotta do goodness
don't stalemate
wow and she and so now what do you think
daniel in this match situation where
you're sean
when you see that your opponent is
capable of stuff like that how does it
change your mentality for the next games
well less free moves is the bottom line
you gotta create a quick profile
of your opponent um then you just
consciously have to say
you know i can hover over a square but
i'm going to take less risk when it
comes to pre-moves
and you have to modulate that on the
basis of who you're playing
so sean's playing fast enough where he
can afford that he's playing super solid
in the opening
and i think that's the change he needs
to make but dc would have won a piece
there
right uh knight b4 this is the type of
knight if you play a3
sometimes you can leave the knight there
well not with the bishop on a6
sometimes he can open up the a file and
hope for more def4 looks good
sean playing super aggressively holding
on to the initiative this is looking a
little bit grim
i'm on for alessia's king i think it's
time to put that helmet on
on the black king he'll need it
and respectable move there just castling
if he plays bishop
uh sorry if she plays bishop b7 as c6
and somehow gets that pawn i think it's
workable
yeah i mean it's so what what you know
what's a couple of bonds
but look at this if we need three you're
right
chance is created very resilient by
alicia
will it be careful for bishop e4 but
then
knight c6 check yeah it's being set up
but it's not going to be good enough
even queen takes is probably good and
yep that's a big one for sean and she's
got to resign
yeah there's there's no stalemate
happening there
gotta go go next go next all right and
this is a very important game for
alessia
okay she's got some experience uh you
know playing
the speed chess championship maybe she
has to bring that to bear
uh change her perception i mean this
this position looks good for her she
played this
in her first white game this is slightly
better for white but something went
wrong when she opened up that f final
exactly she actually had the better
position i thought and i was really
really big fan of how she played it like
um rewriting this knight maybe to d2 f1
and e3 instead she says you know what i
learned from the last match give me that
free pawn in the middle
all right no this is textbook textbook
opening play the knight can come to d5
at the right moment queen back to d2
maybe
this is really good for white knight c5
maybe by sean
get yourself a passpond there don't mind
if i do
absolutely you got the one dollar pass
bond special here
i i love the the textbook you know
russian school just trade
trade the queens off and um
343 or 373. i keep confusing the two
i think the i think the 343 is where
yeah
yeah yes yeah yeah you're right sorry
okay and let's see brooke's on the
seventh though speaking of doretsky
that's actually in there yes it is sean
should have gone
rook f rook on six now alessia just
massacring the king side there
hey the rooks are actually slightly
awkward that's a nice smoke rook a7
measured h4 i would play just to create
some look for g6 is a good move
don't move that rook on g6 though yeah
no
[Music]
iii is good but the king is out all of a
sudden that king is running wild
yeah you gotta just snag all the pawns
but no idea sir
particularly if she trades the rook this
is winning
careful oh i was gonna say maybe king f1
there with rook g2 for a draw but
right that's all you can hope for here
the time is ticking is shawn quick
enough alessia it's got to be too fast
here
yeah and it's over
yep and alessia what's a big one one two
three is our score
time seven minutes it's
a huge game this one a huge case
uh i'd say you know the last game in
this game are you know
comparable in size unfair and hugeness
and let's see with h5 you can see that's
exactly the strategy i like she's a
tactical player
she's got to get these positions sharp
king h1 not a good move
agreed knight f6 queen d7 bishop h3 just
i mean this is textbook attacking
beautiful played by alessia so far don't
forget about that sniper
on a7 all right
knight takes okay castles that's a very
nice move ignoring the pawn on f6 saying
i need to develop
really good yeah that bishop is amazing
on a7 and doubling rooks
okay knight two five is nice h5
yeah what's next though
right exactly what's on the menu oh
okay and pawn takes i mean here comes
rook h8 this has to be a win for alessia
h4
h2 oh goodness
okay uh that was not it probably
still winning though king b8 i
appreciate that move
class
okay take it gift me the pawn
so white is looking to finish the game
preferably with none of his pawns on the
board
but with checkmate on d6 in the bishop
don't move your queen alessia do not
play queen h5
queen g3
over and just move that knight anywhere
nicely done and she just finished that
game all of a sudden i don't know where
check me on the board
this is a very close match it is
and uh she um
you know what she did with uh with
sean's king
she sent it to the dungeon
[Laughter]
that was amazing it only took me about
five minutes to
you know roast up like that one you had
that one prepared and you were just
waiting for the checkmate to actually
happen you're like please get a
checkmate oh my
come on be still my beating heart look
at these squares in the center
this is this might be the worst position
yeah this i i can't really comment on
this but do not trade
knight for bishop that's all i can say
my very first games when i played black
against
you know strong grandmasters i was a
sicilian player and i would
allow these kinds of positions um and
alessia look at rookie i mean
so smooth and so patient with h3
beautiful
oh the other rook to g3 dislodging the
open g6 but sean
be careful after beef oh i was gonna say
leave the rook on g6 play b5
get some counter play it's not totally
simple but now h5 g4 and she takes and
this is completely winning
clinical like uh when alessia gets her
positions
she just destroys really good that
wasn't
that was a phenomenal truly i mean
basically no mistakes no inaccuracies
that was awesome and alessia looks that
she is about to tie the imagination
she's seeing everything right now yup
oh okay okay king uh d1 is covered so
you could go to h1 but i love them
king f1 that h6 knight f5 comes to mind
ah this is oh take the roof
this is even stronger knight f7
checkmate 3-3 what a comeback
that was an insane game but that's like
an easy 95
uh accuracy plus that was gorgeous
incredible bishop b5
check clinical filigree accuracy by
lester now sean
will he be able to stabilize this is
what happened in game one i'm on this
didn't go well for alessia
i would take that on f6 even though i i
know queen takes c3 and d2 is not the
best i like just giving my opponent
doubled isolated pawns and bullets
practically speaking in bullets it's a
good idea but the two pawns up for alice
yeah
[Music]
i know this is actually fine for black i
think anyone
uh who says something in an accent like
that is trustworthy
night before but even is it annoyed
before it wins
basically
kasparov couldn't quite uh conjure the
move knight b4 out of alessia as it's
there
for multiple moves in a row yes i
remember it's corporal i also missed
i missed many new technical
opportunities but it is bullet chest
only it's a young generation anyways
let's see this end game
no oh no as soon as you stop the accent
we see blunders ever
daniels you're doing the knight three
what's going on
okay not over yet look at that knight
cemented
a6 oh that's not it
so the chance is 94 and rookmate on d1
that's the chance yes but you don't want
to get made it yourself h3 by sean would
be a nice clinical move i can see this
happening
f5 the wrong way letting you know
f5 by sean now could be considered yep
playing with some hot coals here
start checking a lesson
careful the king gets out that's really
important
okay i don't know who who whose side is
easier to play here probably sean he's
got the checks
yeah but at this point with that pawn
going down the board i'd like to see her
move the pawn unfortunately she's moving
the king and it's not good enough too
slow she's moving too slowly
yeah sean is he's just demonstrating
good experience here he's not
he's no slouch when it comes to primary
yeah and neither is alessia but i think
she just started
to tell herself like hey let's pre-move
a little bit too late
right yeah it's like i i tend to draw
the threshold sometimes at five seconds
you know
and it's unconditional below five
seconds in these end games every move
has to be a free move
or you'll make one move which takes you
two seconds and the game is over
yep that's that's the difference we
mentioned you know the world of
differences
in in bullet especially when you're
flagging there is a technique to that it
is an arc
yes it is thank you for acknowledging
that bc what's the piece
no there we go yeah this might be her
exit from the competition unless she can
drum up some
alessia battle cry checkmate on h7
yes or maybe i don't even know what
exactly to do
generating a creative instinct oh that's
okay
creative instincts i love this and sean
i love that move too
he's so solid good practical decision
making there should be five two bishops
and up on time so okay we're going to
see a very telegraphed idea here
what do you mean it was totally obscured
that that the bar are you calling that
obviously
zombies oh man there's a rook on each oh
oh take that that's no no it's a little
bit unclear again
but unless it has to move e5 is strong
yep sean keeping us cool here f5
i would lift the other rook to g3
okay
[Music]
what a devilish idea got baited into it
and that is gonna win
the match for sean as i think he looked
over maybe at the match cloth
both of the players did and it became a
realization
and sean is fighting against the smile i
think
yes super nice but i think he can allow
himself a smile unless he's taking off
the helmet
the helmet served her pretty well that
was an incredible comeback of mine but
in the end shawn's nerves hold up and uh
he just played with high class and kept
his composure and he wins
the final match of the first stage wow
that is uh that is quite something um
daniel the match that we
just saw there went down to the wire i
actually thought to come back i was a
believer there
in the comeback uh but eventually not
convincing as sean credit to him
came up with this really devilish trick
as you called it uh to win the match
yeah no that was uh that was well done
by sean as he advances
and uh well in a certain sense of mind
uh one could say the fun is just
beginning
absolutely well we are going to take a
break
as uh as we had have in the past and
remember that we will be back with the
new
guests for the next match in this bullet
chess championship
all-star event brought to you by sign
[Music]
well uh naredinsky it feels like we are
back with
nearly the same matchup we have uh
bartosz here looking dapper
and he's playing a girl in a red dress
uh nemo welcome back
to both of you and nemo uh explain to us
did i miss the memo am i supposed to be
wearing a red dress as well
yeah of course did you not get the memo
that this is going to be a bullet
championship with the theme of
going to prom i like you guys over here
your hoodies looking a little bit out of
place you know like you gotta be in a
prom where
yeah participants are i guess match to
each other so
yeah exactly i don't know how to
pronounce this one but this one shoots
well with uh
nemo's dress so it's a bow tie yeah
okay i wore the red dress because alex
did it so i was like oh man if alex does
it you know i have to follow suit
sounds like you calculated the sartorial
variations
um but nemo you played the very first
match
um do you feel sufficiently warmed up um
is that match a distant memory by now or
are you drawing upon
the confidence that you gain from from
them how do you feel
oh honestly i'm a little bit scared i'm
not going to lie i mean
uh bertash has been improving quite
rapidly at bullet
uh recently i think the first time i
ever played a match against him
i won like super super hard but recently
he actually beat me in a couple of
matches we've played 133 games together
already so the score is currently 80 to
50.
you know like it's gonna be 80 for me 80
for me obviously but he's catching up
he's catching up so
that's the scary part yeah that that
makes a lot of sense bartosz what do you
what do you make of nemo as an opponent
she says you've played 133 games and do
you think that the fact there's only 15
minutes of bullet
you have a good chance against her yes i
guess
today i have fresh minds and also maybe
i'm not the proper world champion
in girls under 14. i'm not streaming for
clg but i have a chance i guess because
once i won a tournament in my uh city
radomsko
so i guess i have an experience in
playing tournaments and it will be a
good fight so
the most important thing there is that
everyone is having fun so
thank you very much for that i could
participate there and i wish
good luck
the players have wished each other good
luck and i can just
speak on behalf of daniel that we're
having a great time and
we love the outfits uh i already said i
want to see more people flagging
in suits and dresses from now on so
we're gonna
get let you guys get into the match uh
obviously best of luck to both of you
and we will see uh someone with a little
bit of polish in them uh winning this
match no matter what
yep super excited all right let's go
all right yes totally i mean i
understood
yeah that sounds like good luck fabiana
means victory so
yeah um resident uh fake
translator yeah i think yeah from now on
i'll just be yeah conducting an
interview dania will be
doing the translations on the side
that's right
i never knew that a north carolinian
could speak polish like this
but um again they seem confident
it's awesome to see a player so well
dressed for tournaments of mine i think
we could uh
we could learn a lesson or two from them
couldn't we
we definitely could but as with uh most
lessons that i'm taught that
i need to learn them quite a few times
before they're committed to memory
yeah no i knew as with opening
variations and um
you know things like tying my shoes
repetition is very very important in the
life of a grandmaster
um and i feel like there's this pre uh
game stage where the players are like
shifting around and moving around
and trying to find the ideal sitting
position and
you can just you can just see it
no you really can though you see it on
both sides here
and we've seen it almost in every match
so far
i think it's probably the the suit you
know and the dress it's like that formal
attire
they they don't have the comfort that
these hoodies that you and i have here
dania
no that's everybody's jealous of us
that's you know they recognize they made
a mistake and um
the game is underway and ganesh uh
that's the schliemann and that's
well he said he'd be playing this in the
you know free stream conversation and uh
he's a man of his work we have a
lopez variation right
and the polish flags donned by both
players here
wow
actually i think there was 95 missed
there in that position
yeah obviously i agree i still like
nemo's well queen takes e3 check was
interesting but
solid by bartish
yeah definitely uh i think the time
though starting to
really favor nemo unless we see oh
that's a piece oh
and you know where black may need to go
after that i mean
he may need to hit up the bartosz to
that game
that one was i provide the local
partners yeah well if there's one thing
that we do know it's that
his local performances are what he's
leaning upon to win this match so
uh i i definitely uh co-signed that
suggestion
no he's a city champion i think if nemo
had known that he was
the city champion she wouldn't have
shown up for the match i mean
this is too much to handle really that's
why he revealed it
only yeah i don't understand
the the bow tie though that's that's the
real intimidating element
yeah yeah no it's nice of him to uh uh
it's almost like he took the the dress
from uh botez live and turned it into a
bow ties live
and you know he came here with that
instead oh my god
no i i ran out of i should have gotten
shampoo
as in the uh drugstore today i i just
kind of didn't know how bad these puns
would be
you know listen you started something
you gotta you gotta roll with it now
roll i started i started the highest
class of funds and you took that down to
match so
we'll hash that out later but you know
what bartus is trying to hash out his
his pawn structure in that d6 pawn and
knight c4
is gonna that's the pawn for white
hashing out done there
oh crunch yeah and i think
oh just trade everything f6 wins on the
spot
we we are in the school of
simplification here
are you sure you're not in school of
making draws and winning positions
that is one of the classes in the school
of sympathy
no it's winning but barely barely
yeah winning yeah f6 though king c
f6 f7 he's not seeing it f6 okay yes run
that pawn
there you go f7 oh whoa
technique demonstrated right in the city
of rodrigo
exquisite one one is the score
[Music]
sort of what we expected from uh from
this match right here
obviously nemo has the the head-to-head
advantage but
it all comes down to this match right
here that doesn't really matter on game
day
just played a6 number one just informing
and he's got a great position after
nine moves i think he might actually be
that's just better winning here from
queen a5b4
yeah queen a5 is going to hurt
okay queen a5 taking maybe a little bit
premature
yeah it's got to happen at some point
he's holding back
it's going to happen on the next move my
prophecy well
yeah here there we go yep we will accept
that prophecy
bishop takes c6 could have been
considered but nemo deciding to bring
her pieces in all look at that
knight f8 i mean knight on g8 feeling a
little lonely a bit of company there for
him
and nemo i like what she's doing
bringing her queen in but parts are
saying no
no you're not
and hang on we're actually seeing like
all of a sudden black is sort of
clogging all the holes and knight b6
knight a4 might be happening
yup this is i don't even know who's
mating whom
and it appears that bartis is the upper
hand here with nemo
now 20 seconds yeah the evaluation bar
is just
on a seesaw at the moment yep and it's
showing no signs of queen of five is
made he walked into it
oh night easter there's tomato why
wouldn't i didn't like 96 there
no there's no chicken how about this
should take c3 in that position
too calm dania no one has that boys
there we go queen c7 queen b6
yeah and queen c6 is queen b6 is gonna
be seen
six is made of three oh no two seconds
that needed to be found no
oh he's gonna live because i can't find
the checkmate
that's a painful one yeah nemo did have
the mate but
not the easiest move to see queen b6 and
you pointed it out that was uh the ko
move
yeah but you know nemo having a little
bit of mercy
um okay this is not you know if bartus
publishes the compilation of his
greatest openings
i don't think this will make the cut
maybe not
but at the same time
he has to handle this properly sorry i
take that back
this might actually make the cut this
looks amazing i
i might pick this up well hang on after
queen d3
we're gonna see some oh wait queen g6
okay d4 now g4
well queen g6 is big brain targeting
bishop takes b6 wins the piece and then
oh no it doesn't because knight b6
there's some amazing tactics there
queen b7 where i'm a simpler person you
know just just let me take a pawn or two
right now both queens are on a rampage
we're running a muck here
queen takes a cell don't get smothered
oh we can we can feel the potential here
queen e7
burbling are the
rising tides of the attack you know what
i'm saying
okay 27. okay so rook c7
in front of the queen is a little bit
awkward actually and nemo
very nice transferring the queen back
for the defense love that
okay h4 is a level-headed move nemo
needs to find a move now
what to do maybe yeah i was gonna say
knight c4 is a super move
it is two pawns up now okay
yeah white is up on time here so nemo's
got to prove something queen d5 is the
move you're planning next
this is very easy to play rooks behind
the pawn watch for rook takes a fight
bartosz might just be dirty
we know alessia would play it right
nice try there with that one but i think
this won't be enough however with the
rook on a1 you can get some
free moves in no oh no no kiki 2e43
this is it was gonna move okay and you
have to win this with the queen
cutting off the king you see what nemo
is doing very professionally
stops the king from accessing
pre-movable squares exactly
exactly and i i see this uh this knight
g8 line against e4
e5 such a hilarious line you develop
your piece get attacked and say hey you
know what uh i'll reconsider
the bro apparently it's called the
brooklyn variation
interesting today i learned i wonder who
the first person
was to play knight g8 probably brooklyn
beckham
brooklyn beckham was that's the daughter
of david
i i thought it personally was uh wrong
spectrum but it could be i i
feel like uh you're probably a little
more reliable here okay
yeah um that was it was necessary to
mention two boroughs
it wasn't an absolute one uh the first
person to play was actually wilhelm
cohen as you're doing some actual
research there
1897. anyways we have an end game
interesting interesting rook d7
well it's actually interesting while we
were talking we're able to get a
completely equal
end game so this actually is a way to
avoid blenders maybe
right and we have a rook trade on the
cards who's better here should be white
white's got the smaller majority
active king nemo's in charge here yeah
yeah king f6 and all those pawns are at
risk of just
falling here i have actually been
quite impressed with nemo's technique
positional end game technique
in this match she's been patient not
without mistakes but
um okay now of course i'll change her
no this is really good stuff by her
bishop c2 and a4 i wouldn't repeat
if i were anymore go bishop c6 i think
she's
she's too trigger happy on the
repetition you're bishop c6 and b5 and
there we go
yeah okay look at this king seven would
have been winning
wow technique so impressive she catches
that free move
this is a class game by nemo but it's
funny that she wanted to draw there
yeah and barger should have taken it you
should have recognized that she was
repeating
yeah and now a very classy technique
promoting to a queen
and now the best thing to do is move the
bishop aside so there's no stalemate
possibilities
uh oh i've done this many times lord
okay we're good she's good luckily that
bishop does not play an impact close
i agree i agree
so three two nine minutes left right
and then here we go yeah the black mart
diemer this is always a fun gamut
opening the f-file
the attack just rages you know as soon
as the game starts basically
yep and in the hands of the city
champion
this is an unassailable weapon and it
does appear to have yielded quite a bit
of
benefit here as the knight transfers in
preparing for the attack against the
weakened king
this is this is great stuff hello f5
there's gonna be a sacrifice
crunch captain crunch this one's over
yup queen h6 is checkmate knight h6 runs
on the spot
rook this is a total rampage knight f7
yeah and nemo says you know what i'm
obviously not gonna win this game
uh the clock is ticking let's get more
more games
brooklyn again yeah
i thought they renamed it coney island
f6 f6 just hurts to watch i can't
this structure traumatizes me these f6
and e6 pawns particularly in bullet
knight c394 knight c5 looks
crushing and look at me i mean the
positional understanding
has been superb yep now you're calling
it queen check
and then queen back to e2 not so simple
though queen sipper
where is the e4
in 96 okay knight f5 knight d6
has to be king knight d6 wow nemo is on
fire with the tactic
yup and that's a win and nemo's again in
front
back and forth they go and there's
actually been a lot of games in this
match i feel
that have uh ended you know well before
the two minutes that the match could go
so we're actually getting a high volume
of games right
no totally
okay if you're ever interested in a
completely closed position i think
is your guy oh god
if you want if saj wanna if you want a
real sag take a look at that bishop on
if there's an ever twitch dictionary i
don't care what other
um games the word might be
applicable in this is the definition of
sag
yeah the widest nipple is like pretty
white people happy right now
oh no oh
bishop on g2 getting pinned down
everything
the queen d3 would have been possible
amman is there a
guinness book of world records for the
most passive game in just history
um yes but it's getting broken
nearly nearly every game here right
oh no nemo just played a phenomenal game
by the way let's not take anything away
h5 bishop g4
oh nice totally sick bishop g4 again
is an idea yep uh queen's hd2 but it was
also a subtle
idea yeah this might be drawn but okay
nemo
seriously uh i'm so impressed by an
email here and
i think if this uh game goes the
absolute distance
uh then there is a chance for a comeback
here
yeah but uh schliemann expert is uh
bartosz it's called
ganesh in sort of eastern europe in
russia
for carl and um
um but
it's not almost looking clinical here
yeah this is the look at those dark
squares
no no this is uh
this is yeah this is not his best
showing in the venus
oh we need seven meat that's uh well we
call that checkmate
yep we do unfortunate as i think
this will be the exit this will be the
exit of bartosz we hate to see him go
but that's
that's too many games behind now as
you'll see that is this the
yes the halloween true to his handle
this handle is
uh what's with the sharp openings um
so he is playing some sharp openings
some not so sharp openings i remember
one particularly sharp opening with this
knight on age one i think
yeah very sharp opening had to have to
wear the safety gloves around that
position
right yeah you know to put on the hazmat
suit and
um you have to get vaccinated before you
even looked at that
okay h5 oh we see at night on g8 so
taking a page from his book maybe i
would go bishop f4 there and bishop b5
exactly something tells me the light
squares are not
97 knight five two yep knight f6
is happening and this is classic a good
night against bad bishop
right or no knight against that bishop
but the point is white still has a bad
bishop so that's right
black goodnight was less important yeah
right
black maintains the edge and we proceed
the absence of a knight is uh quite
irrelevant here
and there could have been an absence of
a bishop right i'm on after
rook takes c3 there could but it's
actually a bad bishop so you don't
generally want to remove that from the
board
right it's actually not negative right
what what move is that
oh there's nothing being h7 oh you
thought there was a mate
oh no no no no no you don't understand
him on he knew that he was sacrificed at
the end
of the win because he could finally
manage to get rid of his bad business
and together getting rid of the king but
that's less important
oh man people who are dressed that nice
should not be losing games like that
that's all i gotta say
gg yep and a smile slight frustration
and yeah that was a phenomenal
match by nemo barters can hold us at up
high nemo just she's on fire
she is she is and she said she was sort
of coming into this match
matches in general
i'm sorry i'm sorry i'm sorry uh i
played four chess really like
i don't know yes she is
say that i just needed to say that
um anyway she does move on and we have
who do we have next
well first we have something an
important public service announcement
right
yes we we we do have uh a few things
coming up so
you know don't go anywhere guys but
before that we want to make sure to give
another big shout out to our
presenting partner do you want to use
your gaming skills in your career
don't forget susquehanna international
group that's sig dania
is it is the leading global proprietary
trading firm it uses game theory and
decision science to win
in the financial markets and to learn
more about s
i g this s i g dot com slash
chess slash chess
slash has to be slash chess it has to be
it can't just be sh that's the game
we're playing here
it is what a bridge and uh that was
professionally presented
thank you i mean i i don't it's
unfortunate when i stream with
robert he gets to do all the fun stuff
you know presenting
the the partners and the sponsors so
it's just a
that that it gets to be me this time
right you get to put on the npr voice
but uh
i'll get to uh refill my coffee that's
what the
rumor has it the rumor has it guys i i
hope that
you're gonna stay here for uh the
upcoming matches
as always we'll get those players in
here but as you heard it dania needs a
coffee refill and we will be right back
with the bullet chess
championship all-star event presented by
sig
[Music]
and we have returned with some familiar
faces
myself grand master danny nardiski are
joined by national master
sean seth and grandmaster maurice ashley
welcome back to both of you
maurice i'm gonna go to you first you
had an exciting match against tanya
just eeked it out at the end and now
you're moving on in the competition
how's the bullet feeling you're just
warming up getting used to it well you
know
reviewing my games apparently i played
like crap in too slow
so what am i supposed to do see if i can
fix all the blunders
and and move faster in the space of 30
minutes
it's going to be hard to do well
sean you're facing the old school um
and how was your experience in the first
match what sort of immediate lessons
are you going to try to apply to do your
best in this match
yeah i definitely feel better being
warmed up but i feel like god play
faster i mean i'm going blunder either
way might as well do it fastly
that's a that's almost the best piece of
advice i think we've heard on the show i
think a lot of us could
could use that one maurice you were
talking about your speed there were
you know some time scrambles where you
had every pre-move working
and then sometimes scrambles where it
felt like you couldn't get the pieces
going so
is is it a matter of just getting used
to it or are you uh thinking about maybe
turning autoqueen on for the next match
i think that is what it is you know this
is the kind of thing where you have to
practice
and practice and practice if you don't
do it then stuff just flies by you and
you're like how did i miss that move
something you'd never miss in a
classical time control or even blitz
so it is what it is i've just gotta put
it on and
again hope that he blunders enough and i
noticed enough of the stuff that i win
the games
fair absolutely maurice one more quick
question
do you ever hear your own commentator
voice when you're playing
um in some critical moments or yasser's
voice
um no because of how can you collaborate
no you're able to just i know we talk a
lot i know we talk a lot of trash and
all that good stuff
but it's funny one i actually don't even
recognize my face when i play
when i see pictures of myself or videos
of myself i'm like
who's that guy he looks like a killer
like
i look mean and angry and ready to go so
i i gotta focus face what i'm playing
i'm not thinking about anything else
yeah that's awesome yeah we all need a
good poker face when we're playing
sean over to you again uh as we you know
we're about to get into this match but
anything you want to say to some of your
uh
notorious believers who i have seen
frequenting our twitch chat
yeah this one goes out for my believers
there again try and make them happy play
with some speed
got it got it that's awesome well we
will
not delay the inevitable any longer this
is
uh an important match to get into uh
maurice sean we'll leave you guys to it
best of luck to both
of you thank you
and the prize fund you can see there
dania is ever more relevant as
players are getting knocked out one by
one and whittling down